hey KF ich bin s meine Frage an dich ist
wieder auf die Idee kommt Musik zu
machen ja und warum du diese
Musikrichtung hast ja das war's auch
schon
CIA ich habe mit 12 Jahren
angefangen ein Musikinstrument zu lernen
das war eine Orgel und für mich war es
eine Art Ausdrucksform also ich habe da
eigentlich gar nicht so groß drüber
nachgedacht einfach nur Musik zu machen
das war für mich eine Ausdrucksform wo
mir die Menschen zuhören konnten und
weil ich ein sehr stilles Kind war habe
ich alles als Kind gemacht wo ich nicht
bei reden Wste das war z.B Sport Kunst
und auch die Musik und die Musik habe
ich halt gemacht weil man mir dazuhören
konnte und ich brauchte dabei nicht zu
reden und das war so mein erster Schritt
zur Musik und warum ich diese Art von
Musik mache ja keine Ahnung also ist
wahrscheinlich das einzigste was ich
kann und ich mache Musik immer so wie
sie mir gerade gefällt und ich kann auch
keine andere Musik machen ich habe
mehrere Jahre auch mal versucht äh
andere Musikrichtungen zu machen aber äh
das war also das war ganz schlimm aus
dem Grunde wenn man dann nichts anderes
kann kommt dabei Unheilig
raus